[Music]
hey guys so it's been a minute since
we've talked about our home exciting
times right now exciting slash dreadful
times because now we started our
landscaping uh what is it landscaping
shopping that's what it's we've been
shopping for landscapers recently and we
just finished another meeting with one
so it's a bit of very interesting
process trying to figure out like
exactly what we want is also our
landscaping grounds are very very some
home it seems like it'd be an easy job
where it's like well you don't have a
lot of room to worry about but because
of the fact that we don't have a lot of
room we should still have to like really
use our brains and like be like really
creative when how we're gonna be using
this space and not just that but also
like weighing our options and making
sure we find someone that does good work
is affordable and it's creative so
that's just been our process for the
past like what like two weeks it's all
in two weeks oh yeah and I think I might
have mentioned on this channel that my
uncle was gonna be doing the landscaping
but we had a meeting with him and he was
just very honest too he was like you
know what I want you to have solid work
and to be honest with you I haven't been
in the game for like a good decade he
hasn't designed something in like a good
10 years so he was like I'm really rusty
I want you to have some quality stuff so
that's kind of where we left it with my
uncle so then that's the reason why we
started shopping for landscapers in a
huge headache but you know what isn't a
headache shout-out to our sponsor tushy
so this video is brought to you by tushy
and in case you don't know what it is
it's a sleek and modern the day
attachment or your toilet so all it does
it just attaches directly to your
existing toilet and it uses the clean
water so the same water that you use to
brush your teeth is the same water that
is being used to clean your booty and we
are huge fans of the day's like all of
our toilets have the days we absolutely
love it
and over time it's been proven that you
can use like up to I think 80% less
toilet paper when you use a bidet so we
love it so much so that we actually
gifted Kerry and Diana Casey's brother
and his girlfriend a tissue for
Christmas this past Christmas and we
absolutely love it it ends up like you
just feel cleaner like it's way cleaner
than just wiping with paper so it's just
like taking a little mini shower for
your butt yeah especially for guys cuz
you guys have a lot of hair down there
and stuff it's like it's like smear
smear like trying to clean something off
of a carpet just with the dry paper it's
not gonna be clean so you've got a power
wash it it's a wonderful image to have
in my head that's the reason why I like
I said all of our toilets have bidets
we absolutely love it and so if you want
to get 10% off your order
make sure to visit hello Toshi comm /
tip and case for 10% off your order so
once again that's hello tushy comm /
tips in case for 10% off your tushy
order so thank you anyway let's go to
the backyard and then we'll actually
show you what we're talking about
because we have shown the backyard and
previous vlogs but since we're talking
about it right now I might as well just
give you another visual he's ready so
during the quarantine I think I spent
the most amount of time in our backyard
that it's quite a beauty out here I'll
show you around it really let me switch
from my indoor sandals
yeah put our outdoor sandals on there
you go all right
lounging aspects of this because of the
umbrella yeah what's the science we
actually had the chairs arranged here
but then when the though in the
landscape for Duluth this last that this
last oh my god my tongue that's a tongue
twister
this last landscape that came here was
like arranging the chairs and just to
visualize we can't fire down around
some brother no future of our
landscaping yeah yeah like an l-shaped
couch and then have like some sort of
like coffee table slash maybe bonfire I
don't know if you guys have seen those
but there's like little bonfire tables
here and and then actually have like a
different kind of umbrella the ones that
kind of come out like this I don't know
we could see like this yeah they come
out like sideways instead of like this
how it was like straight up and down and
that's gonna be in that corner so this
is kind of the idea yeah that's the cool
part so all of this so pretty much from
here cutting it this way and all of that
is gonna be a deck and we're gonna be
hiding the AC unit with like artificial
hedges right there and then because of
the photo and then also the deck you see
how this is like higher slightly higher
we're gonna be trying to make it even a
little bit higher than this so this
entire space here is gonna be slightly
more elevated because we we have a
pretty nice view of the mountain right
here so we we really want to just be
slightly more elevated so we can enjoy
that view it really makes a big
difference though yeah true I know so
we're gonna be slightly higher so pretty
much like where the step is for the
house that's where the deck is gonna be
and then what's gonna be over here you
might think this cooler I'm suspecting
cooler
what kind of girl it's gonna be an
electric stuff here from the deck yeah
like a step down that's down and then
over here is what cement cement like
scoring's it's gonna be a scored cement
so it's gonna look like tile it's a
cheap trick that I'm gonna be doing my
my plan my idea I'm gonna be getting
stencils and then I'm gonna paint on top
of the cement so it's gonna it's gonna
look kind of like like a bootleg version
of type Rock like Moroccan tiles kind of
styles exactly because the design of a
stencil that I'm gonna get it's gonna be
along those lines and so this entire
flooring here because you guys know how
much I love patterns I mean just look at
the whole house filled with wallpaper
and stuff this whole space here it's
gonna be filled with a pattern on the
floor and it's gonna be more cost
efficient because it's not gonna be real
tile it's just gonna be paint on some
mints smart but it's gonna be a pain in
the butt because I've seen people that
have taken on projects and have
stenciled
out like just like a little like like a
rug area of a backyard and it's
literally like the most tedious like
headache-inducing task ever so that's
gonna be interesting so look forward for
those those videos for your do shifts if
you know if you trust Mike I really
don't I'm sorry I love you but I don't
cuz uh yeah there's a lot of attention
to detail and a lot of like really like
meticulous things and you know how I am
so honestly yeah like even though I'm
already starting off by complaining on
that I don't mean to complain
I'm just trying to express how I know
it's gonna be a difficult test but I'm
looking forward to it because I really
like like tedious little things like
that so I I'm not tripping about also
choosing to do this it's exactly I'm
choosing to do timeline of her backyard
is within a couple summer then you'll be
doing this during this however it's
gonna be fun fun so you guys to look
forward to those videos I'm actually I
really can't wait for the day it's done
and then I can look back and see the
time lapse because I plan on like doing
a time-lapse of me doing the entire
entire stenciling all here but it's not
only here that I'm gonna be doing the
stenciling it's also gonna be in the
front so we'll show you that in a second
but in the front it's the similar idea
of the flooring that we're gonna have
here where it's gonna be like scored
cements to be the child and then
the idea well you know what other videos
you could be looking for to to the
cooking oh yeah your favorite yeah like
right here so and then what's gonna be
along that wall
[Music]
yeah like a seating / like prep right
it's gonna be more counter space on that
wall that's how guys do it that's how we
hang down in the backyard
yeah tell men do it rose so we were we
were playing around with the idea of
having like some sort of like here's
like jasmine vine or something and then
also along this wall because we
absolutely do not want just a plain
cream color wall it's very boring all
debentures your backyard years you give
you an answer that's true eventually we
got some weeds growing already yeah yeah
but you've been the one enjoying the
backyard the most since we've lived here
so you're gonna are you gonna be sad
kissing it goodbye at all this dirt yeah
I've been imagining the day that they'll
come and start like actually you like
like leveling the the backyard and stuff
and a part of me is kind of grown
attached to how it looks right now even
though it's like complete mess right now
but like I don't know like I've noticed
like these little we've grown
since day one and never liked this guy
definitely not $40 something smaller
than the static just a little tiny
little ringing poking up for the dirt
but now this guy's grown to this size
and I'm gonna have to sing five man
whenever we do you gotta touch the
weaves of 20 hands mark marked cool this
is Mark yeah mark Marky Marky and market
Marky you just leaving the office
characters Michael in his in their
Scotch okay that's my going oh yeah
so that's exactly the idea back here
we'll see how that goes
we'll see who we end up going with
because we have quite a few contenders
right now and it's kind of crazy because
like when it comes to pricing it's like
boy like exactly a huge spectrum we're
like we get one quote and it's like whoa
this is really really inexpensive
and then we vote out another person a
different quote it's like whoa this is
like triple the amount that the other
one said you were just like I think this
is what adult things all about you gotta
just look at so many different
landscapers and then we're also like
asking friends for any recommendations
and neighbors actually we have been
talking our neighbors and getting
recommendations and it's a lot of that
but actually point out look at this the
Builder still has not fixed this window
come on you're the one talking to him
what happen what do you say Oh in person
he's been very polite and he's a nice
guy actually a really cool guy the
Builder represented he was like yeah
we'll get that fixed immediate
yeah you know how long ago was that that
was a week ago
I haven't told Jesus luckily this is our
biggest problem because if we had other
major issues that would be pretty bad
but I mean that's that's still pretty
wet I mean a broken window for a
brand-new house little baby loose
imagine just a little bunch of these
make it into like a tiny little town
okay like when we went to the to like
studios oh yeah you know be really cool
if if our backyard was still like this
during Christmas
imagine find your like the tiniest
little life yeah I would die I would
love that
good you're just going like you're
inside just go that's exactly what
happens to me oh yeah let's go in the
front all right so this is the front
we're trying to be careful not to give
too much away because we like our
privacy but yeah this is this is pretty
much the entire like front front yard
thing that we're talking about oh my
gosh you in the weeds you're so funny
but yeah so we're gonna get rid of the
mulch right yeah normal it's gonna be
sports and man sport cement makeshift
tiles yep with the painting painting and
then we're gonna get some like there
were like tea tables and or whatever
they call them that's our front yard
front yard yeah
front yard right here
[Music]